former New York Republican congressman
and candidate for governor uh good to
have you with us um Lee zelden thank you
for joining us you know I mean it's so
shocking to hear the change of tune from
the mayor of New York City and and
honestly Mayors across the country who
now that they're actually dealing with
the kind of situations that people at
the border have been dealing with
suddenly they're they're all in favor of
bringing back ice and deporting but I
want to remind people here is what mayor
Adams said back in 21 he said we should
protect our immigrants period yes New
York City will remain a sanctuary city
under an Adams Administration your
thoughts as we wait for this news
conference L Le yeah now his messaging
is about how this is going to destroy
the city and he's right that this is
destroying the city the Manhattan
district attorney Alvin brag didn't even
ask for a bail these individuals who
attack the NYPD officers they're all
already criminal aliens they've already
violated other laws on the books uh for
the mayor of New York City to have any
chance of being able to secure New York
City you have to have prosecutors who
actually want to prosecute so that's an
that's one issue you also have judges
inside of the New York City jurisdiction
who in certain cases won't even set bail
on someone when the prosecutors do ask
for bail uh Albany has passed a number
of bills over the course of the last few
years from Castle baale New York is the
only state in the entire country that
doesn't give judges discretion away
dangerousness uh the halt act to get rid
of the tool of solitary confinement for
correction officers other bills called
raise the age less is more last year it
was called the Clean Slate act to
essentially wipe out criminal
convictions not just of minor offenses
including homicides as well uh so in
order for the Democratic mayor of New
York City to actually bring Law and
Order restored to New York City you're
going to have to be willing to take on
his own party because the same time that
he said that this is destroying the city
he also said that this was the fault of
the Maga Republicans we have to be
honest as far as who has the power here
in this moment and right now uh Joe
Biden and the Biden Administration they
have to get tough on our Southern border
the sanctuary City policies that he was
bragging about In that clip the
sanctuary State policies of the state is
all leading to this moment for New York
City so part of this is maybe an
evolution a bit of rhetoric but we're
going to have to go a lot further than
that because we actually need to see
courage conviction as it relates to
policies well this uh was since deleted
but not before uh it was pretty easy to
to get a look at this Instagram post by
50 Cent who said this WTF mayor Adams
call my phone I don't understand how
this works Somebody explain this I'm
stuck maybe Trump is the answer so I
guess that leads me to my next question
uh which is what is the electoral pols
politics of all of this you also hear
Kathy hokel the governor of New York on
the subway the other day saying you know
round him up and get him out of here
where is this headed
politically uh for many New York voters
for many Americans across the whole
country this has become their number one
issue for many American voters who
didn't even have this as their top 10
issues uh as recently as say the 2022
midterm election uh whether it's
presidential races it is house senate
races it's local races uh a lot of
people are saying that this is the
number one that they want number one
issue that they want to see addressed
the impacts of what's going on on our
border it's not just about people coming
across it's also things uh the whole
conversation about fentanyl the impact
on budgets from housing to health care
and more uh has resulted in these
longtime Democratic voters
disenfranchised by Democratic policies
now looking for conservative Solutions
on topics like this there there there
was a poll that came out yesterday that
showed uh president Trump beating
President Biden amongst Hispanic voters
uh when we ran for governor in 2022 we
won the Asian-American vote uh their top
concerns uh R was spanning from crime
combating anti-asian hate which was
resulting in deaths of Asians uh to
carrying about their kids education they
don't want to see Advanced academics
eliminated in the name of equity they
want merit-based entry into specialty
school they want to get rid of critical
race Theory uh and now you're seeing
people speak up from within the black
community where Joe Biden and Democrats
have long enjoyed a massive uh gap of
support uh but from you know you played
one statement right now from 50 Cent uh
we heard it from Charlamagne The God Who
is uh very popular host on The Breakfast
Club that's where Hillary Clinton showed
up in 2016 and pulled out the hot sauce
Joe Biden says if you don't vote for me
you ain't black and this all is adding
up at this moment where people feel like
they're being left behind by Democratic
politicians so uh this was interesting
as well over the weekend 60 minutes but
you know it's interesting to see how
many places are now covering this story
in a way that they wouldn't prior to
what has happened in the America's
cities um but Sharon alansa did a report
for 60 minutes and she was talking about
how about the people who are crossing
the border and where they're actually
coming from and what their economic
situation roughly appears to be and and
it's not always what people might think
so watch
this we notice middleclass migrants from
China arriving with rolling bags they
told us they took flights all the way to
Mexico we wondered how all all of these
migrants knew about this particular
entryway into California the answer was
in their
hands know about oh tikk oh you learned
on Tik Tok learned on Tik Tok just take
a flight to Mexico and if you uh are
good at walking you can get into the
United States so you don't have to worry
about coming through the regular ports
of Entry uh at an airport when you don't
have the ability to enter the country
and your middle class from
China yeah it's working
there are people who are getting the
message in places far away from the
United States uh that by Design we now
have this open border where Catch and
Release has been implemented uh where on
day one President Biden stopped
construction of the border wall title 42
was eliminated re remain in Mexico was
eliminated uh we saw rhetoric from the
president of the United States to you
played a clip from Eric Adams we saw it
with Governors like Kathy hokel
essentially encouraging uh people to
come to New York let's say that was
December of 2021 with Kathy hok uh and
now they're all changing their Tunes but
the message has gone out that uh that we
have this open border and they're being
encouraged to come and and they're
leaving places across the entire world
to come here and they're getting through
and Reporting back yeah well uh
President Biden when he was running said
you should surge to the Border you
should come and so obviously they
listened uh okay um Lee Elden Thank you
very much good to have you with us today
hey everyone I'm Emily compano catch me
and my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaye
mcki on outnumbered every weekday at
12:00 p.m. Eastern or set your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights